what are some of the things that you
learned with man in a box that knowing
it was your first feature right you
might do differently next time and it
was just through just just practice you
know dealing with someone remotely I
know right you have had experience with
that yeah yeah so okay so I've had quite
a bit of experience with working
remotely and I think that right now it's
actually telling of the times that we
live in because I feel like this is
probably the way a lot of editors are
working right now or definitely going to
have to be working where you can work
with clients literally anywhere in the
world because of the internet because of
the ability to share you know large
files in in faster amounts of time and
so when when Kevin approached me that
was one thing I know was of probably
concern for him it's not the same as
working with an editor right next to you
but you know we were able to use Skype
we were able to text we were able to
email you know send me a hard drive and
I was able to you know utilize YouTube
and constantly you know upload you know
scenes you know so he could you know
watch them or even you know share my
screen and he could see in real time you
know and sometimes tell me oh well can
we move this can we do this so I think
the main thing that I took away from man
in a box versus some of my other smaller
projects is that you really have to be
very organized you know with how you
manage everything including your
communication and sometimes you know
when you have face-to-face communication
you don't have things misinterpreted or
misunderstood whereas with text and
email that's the thing you have to be
very careful about is that you
communicate very effectively to the
people you're working with because you
know they're not they're not reading
your enthusiasm or they're not reading
you know you know deflections in your
voice of how you're saying things so
that's definitely something to be
mindful of even myself the way Kevin
would
you know talk to me and I and you kind
of disconnect you're like did he not
like that because I'm reading this and
I'm not reading it right or you know so
you got to be very you gotta be very
organized you gotta be very clear
you